si de nombreux français ont reproché au
gouvernement durant cette crise son
manque de transparence le chef de l'état
et premier ministre semble vouloir
désormais gérer cette crise
en livrant en français toutes les
informations sanitaires dont il dispose
c'est dans cette optique une carte de la
situation de france région par région a
été dévoilé voilà une réponse directe
aux déclarations du premier ministre qui
cette semaine annoncé que la france
serait dé confinés par étapes en
fonction de la situation sanitaire de
chaque région ainsi les zones en vert
sur la carte pourront sortir dès le 11
mai tandis que les zones en rouge
vivront à déconfinement plus stricte en
attendant de changer de couleur
une couleur qui est lié au nombre de cas
mais aussi à la situation de saturation
des centres hospitaliers en réanimation
et à la capacité locale de tester les
patients olivier ferrand a présenté
trois cartes différentes avec trois
couleurs rouge orange et vert la
première est celle de la circulation du
virus la seconde carte est celle de la
tension hospitalière sur les capacités
en réanimation et la troisième est la
synthèse des deux premières qui présente
la situation globale du pays et pour le
moment c'est elle qui est importante
alors la carte des régions vertes et
rouges dévoilé bonne ou mauvaise idée
[Musique]
alors on va voir donc la carte la
troisième la synthèse des deux premières
cartes qui présente la situation que lui
au global du pays
pour le moment est celle dont glock est
importante alors regardez voilà alors en
rouge en rouge c'est se voit la cc lacq
attaquons rouge donc c'est guadeloupe la
réunion l'aisne les ardennes l'aube le
cher côte-d'or le doubs haute corse le
jura le lot la marne la haute-marne dans
tout ça voilà il ya des sols
hauts-de-seine seine-saint-denis
val-de-marne val-d'oise le nord la
nièvre bon voilà je vais pas tous les
citer mais voilà le ministre expliqué
qu'au moment du décompte final
il n'y aura pas que des départements
vert et rouge mais aujourd'hui nous
avons maintenu des zones orange ces
départements vocation à basculer d'ici
au 11 mai en verre ou bien on rouge donc
ceux qui sont orange que les spéciales
quand on sort euh voilà le ils sont
voilà ils attendent ils sont sur le qui
vive on va dire sortait nom ne sortait
pas non c'est la messe est finie damier
s'adresse à eux ils sont comme dans la
cellule de fort boyard est un jeu sympa
de zorba oui alors certes
ou contre cette carte du déconfinement
une carte que voilà on avait il y avait
une carte even rumeurs de cartes yade ça
à moi qu'on avait relayé on avait dit
c'est qu'une rumeur tout ça mine de rien
on va pas se mentir
elle ressemble énormément à la carte qui
avaient circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
et qui était une rumeur voilà mais elle
est elle je vous dire voilà mine de rien
elle ressemble énormément voilà on va
passer on va pas se cacher les filles
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup tombent
elles ont parlé d'ailleurs est bonne ou
mauvaise idée donc cette carte du
déconfinement déconfinement par région
gilles verdez très mauvaise idée pour
moi la france pour moi c'est un pays
centralisé jacobins je suis content on
dirait koh lanta avec des équipes
différentes mais c'est quoi cette ans
divisé comme il n'y a plus d'état qu'à
voir le soir mais ses habitants
mais je suis content cyril bilbeaud
nouveau révisé l'aude je réponds pas une
mauvaise idée
c'est plus navrante mais si oui mais je
comprends juste jeu qu'on produit que
vous pensez que c'est une mauvaise idée
mais là votre argument il est
franchement on ne comprend pas valérie
parler lui je crois que c'est lui le
vrai avec moi il parle et me valérie
gilles j'entends ce que tu dis sur une
france centralisée mais justement c'est
le problème de la france enfin en forme
n'écoute terrain enfin on va voir les
principaux acteurs sur le terrain pour
savoir exactement ce qui se passe dans
chaque région est ont fait au cas par
cas en fonction de la région
enfin on écoute les préfets les maires
ceux qui sont son père un qui voit au
jour le jour ce qui se passe la capacité
d'accueil dans la région pour pouvoir
faire quelque chose qui n'est pas
unilatéral qui donc serait totalement
injuste parce que il y aurait des
régions qui sont moins touchés que
d'autres à qui on va imposer des choses
n'ont pas besoin et donc y suis très
fier qui on aurait pu peut-être trop
laxistes donc voilà donc enfin on fait
du cas par cas
moi je suis pour cette carte régionale
qui permet justement alors c'est pas
région ces départements ces départements
les départements valérie ça n'est pas
raison ces départements où est mon mari
doit vraiment vraiment moi et moi je
suis pour parce que je veux répondre à
gilles s'est une fois de plus uniquement
une question d'organisation à l'hôpital
les départements les plus touchés
il faut pas que les libérer pour
justement les égéries d'animation
tranquille si tu commences à dire sortez
tous bas en b en île de france par
exemple ait dans l'est où c'est beaucoup
touché ils vont avoir un encore un as
muse
les uns dans les autres quito un afflux
dans les services de réanimation il va
falloir transférer des victimes en tgv
comme on a vu dans les régions ils sont
pas confiés où ils ont moins de
problèmes comme ça c'est très très bien
au cas par cas c'est très bien comme ça
puis doucement
le problème c'est l'île de france parce
que c'est le poumon économique et qui a
12 millions d'habitants en ile de france
donc ça comment on va faire plus
promettre de goût mais ça c'est l'île de
chance cas particulier moi j'ai eu
d'accord est juste une question à vous
qui êtes 13 le milieu de journée
oui vous qui êtes très intelligent tout
ça mais les collègues son plateau mais
on aura juste la corse
pourquoi ça même toit syrie était plus
toi même pourquoi là d'accord saperaient
les rouges en eau et verte en bas alors
parce que ya l'eau il ya là mais alors
alors mon chéri je t'explique pourquoi
je pense pas là parce que la région la
corse la la corse le l'accord corse du
nord a été plus touchée que la corse du
sud en fête
voilà donc notre corps ça ici le plus
touché que le voilà comme simplement
donc forcément voilà c'était ici je vais
dire voilà tu vois que c'est comme nous
tâchons km ta d'état dirigeants qui sont
plus touchés que d'autres
c'est incroyable il s'attend il faudra
affiner et bah c'est l'exemple type
c'est pour ça que j ai pas et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut des consignes et tout
doucement avec des régions qui sont pas
beaucoup touché
comme dans les landes ça ça me laissait
confiné s'ils ont deux cas voilà tu
l'étude est déconfite et en
ile-de-france situ des consignes tout le
monde ça va être réanimation pour tout
le monde
cocktail d'intubation pour tout le monde
c'est pas l'idée est justement ce n'est
pas l'idée alors oui veulent géraldine
maillet pour nous emmener sur la sur les
marchés n'ont évidemment photographie à
l'instant t de comment circule le virus
et comment on est dans le service de réa
à l'exemple à paris qu'à 500 personnes
en réa en lozère ils sont 0
il ya eu la mort en lozère du collier
concrètement effectivement je pense
qu'en lozère déconfinement va être plus
souple plus adapté que nous on y de
france pléthore de poumons aujourd'hui
presque de cluster du comité dont la
finalité aussi c'est qu'il avait dit
avoir fini qu'il me semble il y aura des
zones vertes et des zones rouges
par exemple les zones vertes il y aura
le retour au collège les zones père la
réouverture des parcs et jardins voir
concrètement petit à petit va y avoir
une sorte de 2 selon dire deux choses
qui va se desserrer
j'aimerais vraiment vous me disiez ce
que vous êtes
d'accord avec 7,7 cette stratégie comme
ou non vous raconter ce que vous me
dites pas si vous êtes d'accord il ya
quelqu'un qui aime bien les raisons la
raison les malades encore sont envoyés à
l'hôpital de bastia qui est encore ceux
du nord
voilà c'est ce qu'on dit c'est ce que
quelqu'un me dit voilà il faut avoir la
claque akindès qui va d'avoir une carte
tous les soirs non il y aura pas une
carte tous les soirs mais c'est vrai que
parce que ces gens ne hier voilà mais
c'est leur dernière étape mais c'est
pour le ces pour le cas parce que ça va
ça va pour les oranje déjà ils vont voir
peut-être que demain les oranje y seront
ouverts au rouge
donc c'est un truc de fou regardez il ya
quelqu'un sur twitter il ya beaucoup
d'internautes qui sont amusés il ya des
gens qui vont dire regardez la carte des
résultats pour les départements chaque
soir on va l'attendre comme ça regardez
chaque soir il va avoir la s engraisser
les résultats du bac 1 tu regardes tu
fais mon cv je suis vers l'est mais
cholet on est rouge les journées mortes
à merde pas d'exemple et des marrons et
chocolat lait on à l'oral et honorons je
sais qu'à l'oral sais tu passes à l'oral
je sais c'est pas si on fait ce qu'on
peut voir le tweet de tif s'il vous
plaît la carte des résultats pour les
départements chaque soir on l'attend
comme ça c'est comme dans koh lanta oui
rené vas-y moroni oui moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec deux amis vers les
personnes il ya une loi qui a fait la
nation et pour une fois on donne un peu
le pouvoir aux élus territoriaux
voilà je suis d'accord avec eux cette
carte mais tonale et là il ya des
questions qui se posent moi je suis là
confiné en occitanie cézanne verte
mais si je vais aller avant cette zone
rouge je veux y aller où je passe des
choses dans le rouge
je peux plus partir voilà riche chillar
une faute infectées dans le rouge cédant
rouge
ouais je suis d'accord
4 parce que justement il ya des régions
qui sont pas touchés je vois pas
pourquoi elle serait mise à mal de
papiers il ya des régions de suisse
messieurs et chez les migraineux on a
tendance pas bons on attendra on
attendra donc la carte du déconfinement
tous les soirs et donc je vous dis ceux
qui sont orange qui sont elles
khaldi bas qu'ils vont voir il sépare on
sait pas s'ils ont ou pas